Oh
so now for our first panel as I said the
national debt and entitlement reform our
panel chairman is dr. Gary Wolfram Gary
is the William East Simon professor of
economics and public policy at Hillsdale
College and he is president of Hillsdale
Policy group a consulting firm
specializing in taxation and policy
analysis his public policy experience
includes serving as congressman Nick
Smith's chief of staff and as Michigan's
deputy state treasurer for taxation and
economic policy under governor John
Engler he has also served as senior
economist to the Republican Senate in
Michigan Gary received his PhD in
economics from the University of
California at Berkeley and we don't hold
that against him he's also taught at
Mount Holyoke College the University of
Michigan in Washington State University
his publications include toward a free
society and introduction to markets in
the political system and several works
on Michigan's tax structure and other
public policy issues he was named
Hillsdale College's professor of the
year for 2004 and as many of you know he
is an avid long-distance runner runs has
been a runner for years and is one of
Michigan's
top 25 runners and he has received that
award he and his wife Mary have three
children
please welcome dr. Gary Wolfram
well thank you all for coming I think
Anita wanted to test and see how many of
us actually teach 8 o'clock classes when
she scheduled this and asked for
Berkeley you know people ask me about
that and I just say well as the Grateful
Dead said what a long strange trip it's
been it's really difficult to think of
an issue more important to our country's
well-being than that which this panel is
going to be addressing and it's a very
important issue which the title is the
national debt and entitlement reform and
many of you might be old enough to be
receiving emails from AARP I can't say
that I am but I might have but if you
keep getting these things you know that
these issues are linked together and how
difficult it is going to be and our
panel is going to address this a
difficult that's going to be to try to
deal with this problem the unfunded
liabilities of Social Security and
Medicare are larger than is our national
debt which itself is at record levels
now I like to use music analogies in my
classes and but one thing I've had to
notice I've had to do is that about six
weeks ago I started having a classic
album of the week to let them know
because although Hillsdale College does
teach you the Constitution it seems to
be lacking in rock and roll history so
I've taken that on myself but some of
you will remember Marianne Faithfull and
and she had a song don't make promises
you can't keep
and that would be a fitting subtitle for
our panel what I'm going to do today is
I'm going to introduce all the panel
members and then they're going to come
up in order then at the the each
panelist will have about 20 minutes in
fact anita will tell you they have
exactly 20 minutes and then at the end
we will be able to have questions and
answers and it'll be the form as it was
last night there will be someone with a
microphone so if you have a question
raise your hand and it's
the microphone will come around and give
you the mic first of all I'd like to
introduce that David Henderson he's a
research fellow with the Hoover
Institute he's also an associate
professor of economics at the Naval
Postgraduate School in Monterey
California which as nearly as good a
weather as Hillsdale does his writing
focuses on public policy his specialties
in making economic issues and analysis
clear and interesting to a general
audience which makes him a fantastic
professor as well he's written several
books including the concise encyclopedia
of economics
he is a contributing editor for reason
and writes frequently with the wall
street journal in fortune he's also
served as senior economists for energy
and health policy with the President's
Council of Economic Advisers from 1982
to 1984 born and raised in Canada
Henderson earned his Bachelor of Science
degree in mathematics from the
University of Winnipeg in 1970 and his
PhD in economics from the University of
California Los Angeles in 1976 Michael
Tanner will be following him and he's a
Cato Institute senior scholar and heads
research into a variety of domestic
issues with emphasis on health care
reform Social Welfare policy and Social
Security
his most recent white paper bad medicine
guide to the real costs and consequences
of the new health care law provides a
detailed examination of the Patient
Protection and Affordable Care Act which
goes by other anachronism including
Obamacare and what it means to taxpayers
workers physicians and patients he's the
author of Leviathan on the write how big
government conservatism brought down the
Republican revolution which chronicles
how the Republican Party shifted away
from its limited government roots and
warns that reforms are necessary his
other books include healthy competition
what's holding back healthcare and how
to free it the poverty of welfare
helping others in civil society and a
due deal for Social Security under
Tanner's Direction Cato launched the
project and Social Security choice which
is widely considered the leading impetus
for transforming Social Security into a
private savings program Time magazine
called him one of the architects of the
private accounts movement and
congressional quarterly named in one of
the
five most influential experts on Social
Security
Dean Clancy is Freedom Works legislative
counsel and vice president for
healthcare policy
he studied government takeover of health
care and has an acknowledged expert on
budget and entitlement issues at the
White House Office of Management budget
from 2004 - he was the top US budget
official for health policy and
entitlement issues what we're seeing
half of the federal budget in dollar
terms and more than thirty departments
and agencies from 2001 to 2004 he served
as executive director of the President's
Council on bioethics helped advise
President Bush on stem cells cloning and
similar issues more recently he served
as vice president of government affairs
for KCI a leading wealth leading wound
care products manufacturing company and
as Dziedzic Pfizer to congressional
Republicans on the Senate staff of the
Joint Economic Committee during the
national healthcare debate he considers
his proudest accomplishments to be the
shepherding of the welfare reform Act of
1996 into law and quietly saving
billions of taxpayer dollars while at
OMB kills from Aurora Colorado and holds
degrees from Georgetown and Columbia and
resides was the wife and four children
in Northern Virginia so with that I will
turn it over
thank you and thank you Gary and thanks
to Hillsdale for inviting me to speak
before such a large audience I'm quite
excited about this I want to dedicate
this talk to a former boss of mine who
died suddenly two days ago many of you
probably know him Bill niskanen who was
chairman of the Cato Institute and was a
member of the Council of Economic
Advisers under Reagan when I when I was
there working under him I want to lead
with two quotes countries do not go
bankrupt
that's from Walter Wriston former head
of Citibank here's the second quote
there's a myth that floated around the
banking community not many years ago
that governments do not go bankrupt
I cannot imagine who dreamed that up
there's a ticking time bomb in the US
government's fiscal structure growing
government spending which if unchanged
by policy will result in growing
government debt this is not the
short-run problem you hear about when
you hear about the so-called
supercommittee in Congress it's the
long-run problem that economists such as
Laurence Kotlikoff at Boston University
and Jagdish Gokul at Cato Institute have
been writing about for years and the
problem is this three components of the
federal government budget Social
Security Medicare and Medicaid are
highly likely essentially certain to
take an increasing share of gross
domestic product GDP overall federal
government spending including interest
on the debt could well hit over 40
percent of GDP by 2050 to put it in
perspective it's typically been around
20% for the last 20 years for the last
60 years 20 21 percent on the other hand
revenues government revenues have to
have averaged about 18% of GDP for the
last 16 years never going much below 60
percent and never going much above 20%
so the result if governments don't
change policy would be annual deficits
of approximately 20% of GDP which in
today's dollars would make it a three
trillion dollar deficit it reminds me of
the bumper sticker that I saw when the
Tea Party got active don't tell Obama
what comes after a trillion the question
then becomes what will change and that's
hard to predict and so I'm giving my
predictions in decreasing order of
certainty first federal government
revenues are unlikely to go over 22% of
GDP for more than a few years that's my
big good news today you'll see it has
other implications but I think that's
good news
second well before spending reaches 30
percent of GDP let alone 40 percent the
federal government will face a renewed
more serious fiscal crisis third likely
cuts in Medicare and Medicaid would at
best delay not prevent this crisis
fourth the probability therefore is very
high that at some point the US federal
government will default on its debt and
fifth outright default on the federal
debt will occur despite any increasing
inflation in other words I don't think
the default is going to be by inflation
it could be but that's not the main
thing so how did we get where we got let
me just summarize a whole lot of years
the last 60 years of federal government
spending throughout the 50s defense
spending was over half of all the
federal government spending as I said
federal government spending has remained
around 20% of GDP so what changed
defense spending fell as a percent of
GDP and things like Medicare Medicaid
and Social Security rose almost in
mirror-image to put it succinctly
federal government spending has moved
dramatically away from guns toward
butter
and as you might know the two programs
Medicare and Medicaid were started by
President Johnson in 2009 federal
government spending on Medicare and
Medicaid alone totaled over five percent
of GDP or about a quarter of the u.s.
government budget it wasn't just Johnson
though Johnson and Nixon added
substantially to Social Security
benefits together they raised benefits
in their times in office by 72 percent
when Wilbur Cohen Johnson's Secretary of
hewi said he wanted a 10 percent hike in
Social Security benefits Johnson said
come on Wilbur you can do better than
that
Nixon added to it by increasing benefits
by 20 percent when he was worried about
competing with Wilbur Mills in the 1972
presidential election so why are these
things rising Social Security has spent
at rest spending is rising due to
demographics we aren't going to see
those big increases ever again but we
started from that big level Johnson and
Nixon put us at and we're going up from
there
Medicare spending is rising due to
demographics and one very important
actually pretty neat fact about health
care spending they can actually do
things now 60 years ago doctors
essentially diagnosed you sat in the
hospital and died or didn't die but they
didn't do much about it and now they can
do things and if you've I'm sure a lot
of you follow the kinds of things they
do now and the interest of time I'm not
going to list them all off of course the
mere fact that you can do something
medically doesn't mean you will do it
but if the government is paying for it
you're likely to and with Medicare
people are generally spending other
people's money and we always spend other
people's money much more generously than
we spend her own Medicaid spending is
rising for the same reason although by
the way there were some major increases
in Medicaid coverage in the late 1980s
as David Stockman who was OMB director
made the short run really bad trade-offs
in my
you giving henry waxman from southern
california big increases in spending in
the future in return for tiny cuts in
the present and so the net effect has
been a massive increase in Medicaid
spending over the last or over those ten
years and then again we're going up from
that level moreover a huge component of
Medicaid spending is for nursing home
coverage and again we go back to
demographics there are a lot more people
taking advantage of that
how about projected spending the numbers
in the future are positively scary three
years ago the Congressional Budget
Office a relatively nonpartisan score of
government budgets predict projected
that in 2050 Social Security would be 6%
of GDP Medicare eight point nine percent
and Medicaid three point one percent
that means they would take up 18 percent
of GDP remember all of federal
government is typically 20 percent of
GDP so that leaves two percent if you
want to stick at twenty two percent for
everything else defense other things
government does and interest on the debt
so of course there's just no way now the
most striking fact about federal
government revenues of all kinds since
1950 and I just I said this but I want
to emphasize it is that except in one
year they've never exceeded 20 percent
of GDP and in that one year of the year
2000 they were 20 and a half percent of
GDP in the sixty two years from 1950 to
2011 federal revenues of average 17.7
percent of GDP in recession years they
tend to be lower as a percentage EDT
mainly because as real income declines
revenues decline even more and because
governments tend to follow Keynesian
policies of tax cuts during recessions
so in 2011 for example not literally a
recession year but a slow growth here
federal revenues are fourteen point four
percent of GDP the lowest they've been
in over six
two years and let me show you what the
that graph there tell the on the
left-hand side is 1950 on the right as
2010 it looks like it bounces around a
lot but remember the base there is 14
not zero so it's bouncing around
generally around 18% of GDP up or down a
point or two now that's a kind of an
amazing fact what it says is given all
the tax cut rate cuts and tax rate
increases that have happened over those
60 years bracket creep due to inflation
we still stay within this relatively
narrow range you might think there's an
iron law of economics that says it's
economically impossible for the federal
government to take more than 20 percent
of GDP and revenues and indeed Kurt
Howser formulated such a law
wrote wrote it up in The Wall Street
Journal and called it Hauser's law I
don't buy that and in my paper which I
don't know if I have time time to go
through the reasoning totally but let me
let me try when government raises tax
rates it discourages growth so if we're
taking tax revenues over GDP GDP is a
little lower
Tett therefore tax revenues ought to go
higher as a percent of GDP there is a
laugher curve effect but it's got to be
a very very strong lap for curve effect
to make tax revenues go down as much as
GDP did so Hauser's explanation really
doesn't explain it so I don't think
there's an economic iron law of
economics that says that but I do think
there's an iron law it's an iron law of
politics we have in this country
essentially a political equilibrium
where revenues can't go much below
seventeen percent of GDP for very long
and can't go much above 19% of GDP for
very long why is that so I'm not totally
sure but I don't think I have to be sure
to say there's this equilibrium
there's this iron law so that has and
let me just point to a wine
administration where we can see that
iron law and practice in this one
administration that has still talked
about by some economists and historians
as if it was entirely a tax cutting
regime and it wasn't we see that in
practice and I'm referring of course to
the two terms of Ronald Reagan Reagan
came into office when high inflation had
been combining with unindexed tax
brackets not indexed for inflation to
drive revenues very high in 1981 for
example revenues were a relatively high
19% of GDP in response Reagan introduced
his tax bill I think one of the best tax
bills ever to cut marginal tax rates
starting in late 1981 in stages through
84 and then to implement inflation index
in 85
but as Ronald Reagan used to say let's
take a trip down memory lane as soon as
the summer of 1982 Reagan reversed
course and successfully pushed Congress
to moderate and even reverse some of the
tax cuts Reagan also increased taxes
substantially in 1983 and 1984 similarly
on the other end a president who tried
to increase taxes as President Clinton
did successfully in 1993 sets in motion
forces that try to moderate the tax
increase we see that those same forces
in the opposite direction and the
Clinton administration we got a
substantial tax cut in 1997 out of
Clinton so I really do think there's an
iron law there let me look to the future
I think the most important relevant
political economic fact the thing I'm
sure I saw and all the things I've
talked about is that tax revenues will
not go over twenty two percent of GDP
for more than a year or two and I don't
even think though
that but by 2050 as I noted the CBO
projects that those three programs will
take 18% of GDP other nine interest
federal programs they predict will take
seven point six percent of GDP down from
nine point nine percent today in 2007
and federal the interest in the federal
debt will grow the result by 2050
federal spending is projected to reach
41 point eight percent of GDP roughly
double the average of the last sixty
years
but couldn't the federal government turn
things around by cutting discretionary
spending substantially now and
implementing changes in Social Security
Medicare and Medicaid that would
substantially reduce their rate of
growth sure they could and the recent
attempts by Republicans in Congress are
a step in the right direction
moreover two prime ministers in Canada
where I was born in John Christian and
Paul Martin both of the welfare status
Liberal Party did just that between 1994
and 2006 they brought Canada's debt to
GDP ratio down from 70 percent to 30
percent they did have the advantage of
working in a parliamentary system for
what the prime minister says goes and we
don't have that advantage still we did
have some success in the nineties so
it's possible the problem is politicians
tend to want to kick the can down the
road making it someone else's problem
and not and not really solving these
things I remember in the famous Atlantic
Monthly review of an interview of David
Stockman in 1981 that got him in so much
trouble one thing that no one
highlighted except me and a couple of
articles where Stockman was asked how
come he went for these short runs Social
Security cuts rather than long run maybe
increase the age at which people got
Social Security and so on and he said
quote in 1981 he said quote why should I
solve the problem of the guy who has
this job in 2010
guess what it's now 2011 well things
that can't go on forever as my former
boss at the Council of Economic Advisers
when I was a summer intern in the Nixon
administration my former boss herb Stein
said things that can't go on forever
don't so they'll stop
how will they stop we don't know but it
will take very substantial reforms very
soon to turn it around and I guess I'm
not very very optimistic about that now
many people actually that this this my
papers co-authored with Jeff Hummel and
we've made this case to others and they
actually many people look at our numbers
and agree with our case and they say the
way it's going to happen is that the
government will do it by printing money
they'll essentially default on the debt
by inflating it away that's possible but
what I point out on this paper is it
doesn't work I don't just mean you get
high inflation I mean the government
can't make enough money with high
inflation to make much of a dent the
money the government makes with high
inflation is called senior age and
senior age has been falling even in the
great inflation of the 1970s senior age
was below two percent of federal
expenditures or less than half a percent
of GDP that's partly the result of
globalization in which international
competition disciplines central banks
but it was also the result of
sophisticated financial systems with
fractional reserve banking in which most
of the money people actually hold is
created privately by banks and and
therefore the government doesn't get any
revenue on it so senior age has become a
trivial source of revenue and not just
here but in most other countries you
have to have a very unsophisticated
banking system such as in Zimbabwe for
some for seniors to make much of a dent
so that doesn't mean it won't happen but
if we do a straight-line extrapolation
it would say that the only way the
government could make enough money with
senior age is to have an annual
inflation rate of two hundred and forty
six percent I don't think that's likely
I think people would resist that more
than and there was resist the government
defaulting on the debt when you consider
that the government is defaulting on
people in China and Japan and so on who
can't do much about it so how might such
a threat how much might such a default
unfold the financial structure of the
United States government has currently
has a nominal firewall between Treasury
debt and the government's unfunded
liabilities provided by the trust funds
of Social Security Medicare and other
programs these give investors the
illusion that the shaky fiscal status of
Social Insurance has no direct effect on
the government's formal debt but
according to the latest intermediate
projections of the trustees the hospital
insurance Medicare Part A trust fund
will be out of money in 2024 whereas the
Social Security trust funds will be
empty by 2036 so if the government
starts dipping into general revenues the
firewall is gone if investors then
respond by requiring a risk premium on
Treasuries the unwinding could move very
fast much like the sudden collapse of
the Soviet Union or the more recent
fiscal crisis in Greece politicians will
be unable to react fast enough to close
the gap and for the u.s. government
unlike Greece's there's no one left to
bail us out now this is a kind of a
sobering talk right and Here I am
smiling what am i smiling about smiling
about one thing
- well two things one is I really do
believe that
in law in other words government can't
spend what they don't have and if they
can maybe raise 20 or 22 percent of GDP
in revenue and that'll be it and default
isn't all bad think about a lot of I bet
a lot of people in this group would like
to see a balanced budget amendment one
of the big problems we have with the
balance of budget amendments that
doesn't have teeth how do you enforce it
if Congress wants to borrow how do you
stop them send them to jail
but but who's going to send him to jail
the president so default I'll leave you
with this thought this little bit of
optimism default on the debt is a
balanced budget amendment with teeth
well thank you I'm glad that I have the
opportunity to follow the optimistic
speech because usually before mine they
take away your belt and shoelaces and
any sharp objects at any rate I do out
before I start the thing kills Dale for
giving a chance to come here back to
Atlanta actor was here for an Atlanta
for a couple years of the Georgia Public
Policy Foundation before I went to the
Cato so soul of Atlanta we're all if you
if you all know I mean if you read Paul
Krugman you know that we're living in a
new age of austerity and that the
federal government is starved for money
because those intransigent Republicans
in the House have refused to go along
with raising taxes and spending we went
through a near government shutdown if
you recall back and in May over the
continuing resolution and and then we we
almost defaulted on the debt with the
debt ceiling increase and as a result of
this we have slashed to the bone
government spending and you know it
might surprise you therefore to learn
that actually federal government
spending this year is up by five percent
it's up about one hundred and twenty
billion dollars this year over the first
nine months of the year and as a result
of that of course our you know we've
been borrowing that 120 billion dollars
so our deficit is actually up this year
so and it might not be quite as austere
as dr. Krugman thinks the other thing of
course you you know if you've picked up
the newspapers at all recently is that
there is this huge crisis going on in
Europe that they just manage the fact to
bail out Greece couple of days ago
and you know they're having this huge
crisis because in Europe they've run
that welfare states there have run up
these enormous debts that they can't
possibly pay they are in danger of
defaulting governments there are
actually going broke and and all
fortunately that could never happen to
us well I actually I'd like to take a
little look at that and try and put us
in sort of perspective of what's going
on in some of those countries if we put
that up on the screen it's fine it's on
here it's not on over there there it is
this is deficits as a percent of GDP and
us here is the light line over on the
side there and I just wanted to point
out that as a percentage of GDP our
current deficit is higher than that of
any country in the EU our current
deficit has presented appease just under
11% which is higher than the deficit in
Greece as a percentage of their GDP so
where we're running a bigger deficit
right now than Greece is and then of
course you want to look at it as a
matter of debt the deficit being how
much we're overspending irresponsibly
this year the debt is accumulate an
accumulation of how much we responsibly
overspent from past years combined our
debt is somewhere just under a hundred
percent it's actually 98 percent I
believe of GDP as of last month which
puts us fortunately we're not the worst
in the world
Greece and Italy are worse than us we're
the third worst country in the world
when it comes to the debt as a percent
GDP we're number three but we're rising
you know where we've got that we've got
hope for the future you know we will get
there will will over overtake them but
you know and yet when we talk about we
have a you know debt this month actually
by the end of this month
we'll hit fifteen trillion dollars in
national debt in this country and we
will be at about 100 percent of GDP
everything about that you know we will
owe an amount equal to everything that
this country produces over the course of
a year but that's actually the good news
because when you look at debt there are
actually three different types of debt
that's out there when a government has
dead it actually runs that in a couple
of different ways the first of these the
one that economists or take most
seriously is debt to the public this is
the debt that government owes to people
I'd always said owes it you know it's in
your debt we notice to you if you have a
government bond it always it to China it
always did to businesses state and local
governments who bought government bonds
it's the debt that someone holds and
government often thinks that this is the
mowers or economist thinking this is the
most important debt because first of all
it's the most real debt this is in the
absence of a default to debt that's
hardest to default on that you're
supposed to actually have to pay back to
somebody it is debt that squeezes out
borrowing in the private sector so it
has that the impact there on interest
rates and things like there's this debt
that people worry about and we do are we
are at the highest ratio of that public
debt to GDP that we've had around 60
some-odd percent right now and it is
consider one of the highest since wolf
World War two considered a serious
problem the second type of debt is
what's called intragovernmental debt
this is money that the government owes
itself in effect it's money that the
government has in the various trust
funds and revolving accounts and things
like that most of that money is held in
two accounts the Social Security trust
fund and the Medicare trust fund it's
also in the highway trust fund things
like that this is money that the
government
basically is going to have to pay back
at some point to to itself in order to
continue to pay benefits that's out
there you know the Social Security trust
fund we often get this huge debate in
Washington it's a wonderful food fight
about is the Social Security trust fund
real you know once I talk about all
they've looted that Social Security
trust fund and the other side says know
that you know it's a government debt
it's it's out there it's it's in a vault
in West Virginia the Bob Byrd memorial
vault and it's actually there but it
really is through government bonds
there's little filing cabinet they have
the government bonds in there they're
right next to the Confederate war bonds
you know in reality I would say you know
it doesn't make any difference
you know it's totally irrelevant to the
Social Security system or to the federal
government I mean when you think about
it if Social Security didn't have a
trust fund what would happen is about
seven years from now six years from now
Social Security's good going that
actually feels great right now is
running a cash flow deficit and so their
what they have to if they didn't have a
trust fund in order to pay the benefits
they'd have to go but you know they'd
have to raise taxes or borrow money from
China or find money somewhere in the
budget and pay it well they've got this
trust fund they go out to West Virginia
and they take one of the bonds out of
the Bob Byrd vault and they they cash it
in and where do they get the money to
repay it well they raise taxes or they
borrow it or they find it somewhere on
the budget it's exactly the same same
thing so this is yet just like any other
debt they have and then finally there's
this in what's called an implicit debt
that governments have this is this is
the debt where we've promised benefits
under Social Security and Medicare and
we know there's not enough tax revenue
that's going to come in and with to pay
those obligations and you have that
shortfall now some people say well
that's not real debt but the fact is
under current law it is I mean those
benefits are in the books they are they
are the benefits that current law says
you must pay and you don't have the
revenues to pay them so you have this
debt now you can default on them much
easier they're defaulting on the
government bonds because you can all
please change those benefit formulas but
somebody would actually have to come in
to do that you'd actually have to raise
the retirement age or change benefit
formulas or do something in the future
but if you don't do it if you just keep
the current level of benefits under
current law and you have the current
level of taxes that are coming in
eventually you're going to have to
change that implicit debt over to
explicit debt you're going to have to
find money with which to continue to pay
those benefits which means borrowing it
which means you're going to run up debt
it's going to be more explicit gonna be
more on the books debt so when you look
at the actual indebtedness of a country
if you wanted to look at the balance
sheet of a country what you would
actually want to look at is not just the
on the books debt that is debt held by
the public and intergovernmental debt
the debt we sort of think of as the 15
trillion dollar national debt what you
actually want to look at it's the total
indebtedness of a country which includes
both that on the books debt but also
this implicit debt the unfunded
obligations of its pension systems and
its healthcare systems it's not
something just at the U it just the US
has this is a problem in these European
countries that well they have national
day of unfunded pension obligations that
are all over the place the fact some of
the countries that look pretty good
today like Germany because they're
fairly low national debts have enormous
unfunded obligations of their pension
systems the retirement systems going
forward that are in hundreds of percent
of their GDP going forward so they are
really in the long term and enormous
problems well how do we stack up if you
actually want to look at that
we're number one over at the end there
you can barely see it on the way the
slides are here but our total debt
counting both the national debt with
it's on the books and the unfunded
obligations we face under Social
Security and Medicare are nine hundred
percent of GDP roughly a hundred and
twenty trillion dollars that's trillion
with a t that's the discounted present
value of those obligations by the way
so if we only had a hundred and twenty
trillion dollars today that we could
stick in the bank and earn a 3% rate of
interest we could pay off all our bills
unfortunately a federal government
hasn't got a spare 120 trillion laying
around out there in fact one of the
things to just put this in perspective
you know we've right now we have all
those folks out there on Wall Street and
there's an Occupy Atlanta I understand
that's and they're occupying Takoma Park
where I'm from but that's the whole town
pretty much but you know they say all we
have to do is tax the rich and we can
solve this this problem well if you
we're not just to tax the rich but you
were to confiscate every penny owned by
every millionaire and billionaire in
America you would get about 12 trillion
dollars we owe 120 trillion so you
wouldn't come close to dealing with the
problem and once again to say just
pointing it out here Greece which is
considered the basket case of Europe
it's just about the same boat as us but
we are much worse off in terms of total
indebtedness than countries like the
Netherlands or Portugal or Spain or
Italy that are considered to be in
crisis in Europe today
so the question we get becomes can we
continue to go on the way we're going on
moreover I would suggest you that the
debt isn't even the problem the debt is
just a symptom of the disease now Milton
Friedman used to point out that it's not
debt versus taxes that's the issue the
cost of government is how much
governments spend
and it doesn't really matter whether you
finance that through debt or higher
taxes there's their distributional
aspects of it and what have you but that
but you're both are taking resources out
of the productive sector of the economy
and turning them over to the
unproductive sector of the government
and so what you really want to look at
is how much does government spend and as
you just heard from David if you look
out to around 2050 under current CBO
projections the federal government will
be spending 42 percent of GDP and from
there it goes to numbers that are just
inconceivable I mean 64 percent of GDP
before the end of the century spent by
the federal government and that's just
the federal government state and local
governments traditionally spend another
ten to fifteen percent of GDP so as you
could end up with is government at all
levels in this country consuming
somewhere around sixty percent of GDP by
the end of this by the middle of the
century now think about that six sixty
cents out of every dollar that's
produced in this country would be
consumed by the government may need some
point you do cease to become a free
economy and again just to put this in
perspective if you want to match that up
we think of the the socialized states of
Europe we think of you know the welfare
states of Europe and they do haven't you
know they consume an enormous amount of
their of their economies the government
consumes an enormous amount of economies
in Europe well if you look at where we
would be around 2050 consuming at all
levels of government close to 60% we
would be the second biggest government
as a percentage of economy in the world
compared to where Europe is today I mean
we know that we think of France France
the socialized country over there you
know that we call compare ourselves to
we would be spending more
or have the government spending a larger
percentage of our economy than Frances
today
so we would be more socialized than any
of the welfare states of Europe if we
keep going down the path that we're
going down now when we talk about why
are we heading down that is you heard
it's largely a matter of the entitlement
programs that we face I mean people talk
about we're gonna make cuts in
Washington and they everybody's gonna go
find fraud waste and abuse and they're
gonna cut fraud waste and abuse out of
Washington the problem is you can't get
there from here
domestic discretionary spending which is
where all that fraud waste and abuse is
going to go come from amounts this year
to 650 billion dollars now deficit we're
running is 1 this year will be 1.3
trillion dollars that means you could
abolish all domestic discretionary
spending everything the Department of
Education the Department of Commerce the
Department of Energy's you're going to
hear about coming up the FDA the FBI I
mean it's a libertarian dream and we
still have a 650 billion dollar deficit
this year now defense is another 19
percent of federal spending so you could
throw that in and we'd still have a
deficit the fact is you can't get there
from here unless you're willing to deal
with the entitlement programs of
Medicare Medicaid and Social Security
but no politician right now is willing
to touch those programs all we have you
know we do have you know big debate over
whether or not it's a Ponzi scheme and
we you know we we but if you really look
at it what proposals are out there on
the books right now are on the
seriously be considered for dealing with
these programs and I would suggest to
you that there aren't any oh there's
some trends here and there but no
structural reforms and unless we're
willing to do those type of structural
reforms to fundamentally change the
nature of Medicare and Social Security
then we're headed down that road that
turns us into one of those welfare
states like Europe unfortunately not
time to go into details of how I would
reform them but I would suggest that
ultimately both Medicare and Social
Security are going to have to be changed
from programs that are essentially Ponzi
schemes with a gun
people ask me is Social Security a Ponzi
scheme and I would suggest it would have
been if Charles Ponzi had had a gun
because the difference is Ponzi schemes
go broke when you can't convince people
to keep giving money to as the deal gets
worse and worse and eventually can't
convince people to give them any more
money the federal government doesn't
have that problem now no matter how bad
a deal Social Security gets they could
force you to contribute and the same
with Medicare but unless we change these
from simple transfer programs and which
what we do is take money from working
people and give it to retired people and
no investment takes place and no savings
takes place and no economic growth takes
place then ultimately the system's break
down and you end up with the type of
debt and the type of deficits that I've
been talking about so ultimately you
have to change the nature of these
programs and that is going to require a
level of political courage that is
fundamentally missing in Washington in
terms of Congress but also in terms of
the presidential campaign that we're
currently seeing thank you all very much
appreciate it
all right well thank you well who here
wants to do something about the problems
that have been outlined this morning all
right
well that's what we and the tea party
movement are determined to do we don't
trust Washington to solve this problem
this crisis but we do believe we're
hopeful that the American people can
solve it it was mentioned that I'm with
Freedom Works my name's Dean Clancy
again and just to to clarify where I'm
coming from I've been with the Tea Party
movement since 1773 and now I spend my
time going around the country talking to
people about the budget and about
healthcare replacing Obamacare and
saving our country so what I'm going to
do here is give you a little taste of
what we do as we go around the country
talking to folks about this through a
process we call the tea party debt
Commission and it's going to be
interactive so be prepared to do a
little bit of town hall here with me in
a minute a little bit about Freedom
Works we are a national grassroots
organization of more than 1 million
we're now approaching 2 million members
dedicated to the principles of lower
taxes less government and more freedom
that's what we do and Freedom Works is
different from other conservative
organizations in that we're not about
just educating we're doing that that's
why I'm here today but we're about the
ground game get-out-the-vote elections
we believe that politics goes to those
who show up so our business is to make
sure people do show up and that they're
armed with the right information that
will help them make choices that will
send people to Washington and your state
legislature that actually change policy
in the direction that you think it
should so so we send out door hangers
and yard signs we give people walking
maps we give people information as I
said that's what we're about
the Tea Party debt Commission is a
process designed to help people
understand the budget and it's our way
of hearing from them what they think
Washington should do we're going to be
unveiling a Tea Party budget on November
17th in a joint house-senate hearing and
it's going to be pretty exciting
unlike the super committee we're going
to save which super committee is
supposed to save 1.2 trillion dollars
over ten years our budget plan is going
to save 9 trillion over 10 years and the
difference is our plan is going to be
able to actually balance the budget
actually shrink government actually stop
the debt from accumulating and therefore
avert the future that my two predecessor
speakers have described the the politics
of entitlement reform which is the title
of my talk is difficult clearly because
woops my slides are showing and what can
we turn the slides off thank you the the
politics of entitlement reform is
difficult for three reasons I think
entitlements represent for folks first
of all security people like the fact
that they are guaranteed something
second represents justice for many
people hey this is my money coming back
to me I paid in and finally welfare
people like getting free money from the
government and when you combine those
things with a misperception that this is
also a legally vested right legally
enforceable property the courts will
protect me from the legislature with
respect to this money then you have a
very politically powerful combination
and it becomes a real difficulty to
touch these programs Medicare and Social
Security of the largest federal programs
the fastest growing and that's and
because of these reasons I just
mentioned they're very hard to deal with
and yet we have to if we're going to
avert the grease style debt crisis that
we're we're facing now the
I want to differ from one of my
predecessor speakers David Henderson I
agreed with everything he said his talk
was excellent but he said there's an
iron law that in this country we simply
will not pay more than twenty twenty-one
twenty-two percent of the economy in
taxes to our federal government I don't
believe that law is made of iron it
might be a tin law it might be aluminum
but it's not iron and I have two reasons
for saying that first in the 19th
century the idea that we would have
supported the kind of government we have
today 25% of the economy being consumed
by the federal government you know
people would have drawn their
six-shooters on you to even suggest such
a thing the culture has changed our
politics has changed our the
relationship between citizen and
government has been changed by the
progressive revolution and and a whole
century now of the unfolding of those
sets of ideas and then the second reason
I don't believe it's an iron law is
because the Europeans look to be our
future if we continue on our current
course and now I would like to pull up
the slides
I have a technical difficulty the slide
is not expanding
all right I think we're getting it
thanks for your patience
this that's the slide I want this is the
second reason I don't believe in an iron
law of maximum taxes the blue line at
the bottom of this slide is the amount
of the economy our federal government
collects in revenues since 1965 and
David Henderson is absolutely right
it never goes above about 18 percent of
the economy and it doesn't matter how
high the income tax top rate is it could
be 90% as it was in the 40s and 50s it
could be 70% is in the 60s 50% is in the
80s Ronald Reagan got it down to 28%
before he left office today it's crept
back up to 35% it doesn't matter
we always collect the same amount in
taxes it's because people shift money
offshore they go underground they
exploit tax shelters loopholes and so on
and so that part of the law is iron
people do evade paying more than about
that amount but look at that red line or
maybe it's not clear that it's red the
higher line that's Europe they collect
today over 40% of their economies the
big countries of the continental Europe
40% twice that the tax take of this
country why is that they have something
called a value-added tax on top of
steeply graduated income taxes they
found a machine that politicians can use
to raise enough revenue to consume that
much of the economy and people can't
evade it
people try to evade taxes in Europe to
their culture is different but they
don't like paying taxes any more than we
do really and so that's our future I
believe if we do nothing but of course
we're trying to do something next slide
last slide this is our budget and we try
to educate people around the country
about the composition of the budget as
you can see on the left three programs
constitute 40% of our budget Social
Security Medicare and Medicaid as it
happens our deficit right now is about
43 percent we're borrowing 43 cents out
of every dollar we spend we if we just
lopped off those three program
eliminated them today our budget would
be balanced we're we're we're raising
enough revenue to pay for everything
else on that slide to the right of that
central line defense is about 20% of the
budget net interest about five or six
percent income security which is you
know entitlement programs like food
stamps and unemployment the EITC housing
assistance that's another about 20% of
the budget and then when you get down to
the right lower right corner of that
slide you have most of what we think of
as government FEMA HUD commerce state
transportation state department you name
it I like to always point out the little
pink area there about halfway down on
the very far right hand side I'm
pointing to it with my my laser pointer
that's foreign aid a lot of Tea Party
audiences are a little surprised to
learn that half of our budget isn't
given to foreign countries and you can't
balance the budget by cutting foreign
aid or incidentally by eliminating
earmarks or by cutting illegal aliens
off from government programs or by
cutting out pork or waste fraud and
abuse all of those are good things but
the fact is you do have to go to
entitlements to solve the problem
long-term now that's the the end of my
slides so if we could turn that off
thank you now let's go into the the Town
Hall section of my my talk let me set
that up the Tea Party debt Commission is
gathering information from folks we're
trying to do this different from
Washington the super committee is an
insider game twelve powerful members of
Congress appointed by four powerful
members of Congress Reid Pelosi
McConnell and Boehner and it's got a lot
of power because its bill will get an
up-or-down vote no amendments no
extended debate or filibuster a lot of
power now they're probably going to fail
or they're going to come up with
something disappointing and even if they
meet their charge of 1.2 trillion
it's not going to solve the problem it's
it's really a pittance it will reduce
10-year spending from 44 trillion to 43
trillion yay so that's why we're trying
to do something different and as we go
around talking to people we're taking
their ideas what would they do to solve
this problem also online we're taking
submissions and you can submit at info
at tea party debt Commission com
and finally this online survey which I'm
about to show you in fact we're going to
take the survey together and what we're
doing with that survey is getting a
sense of people's priorities assuming we
have to cut and the debt crisis is
coming so we're going to have to make
choices
what would you cut first okay let me see
if I can set this out
okay is it up alright so you come to our
website Tea Party debt Commission and
then you click here it's not really very
responsive but you come to this website
Tea Party debt Commission calm and now
you what you do is and I'll explain you
you're going to be given a series of
pairs of randomly selected budget cuts
we have a database in here of potential
budget cuts which we've taken from
various plans Cato found Cato Institute
Heritage Foundation the budgets is
proposed by Paul Ryan and Rand Paul and
the house conservatives and so on and so
on and we randomly paired two cuts and
you have to pick one
you can't pick both though a lot of
people would like to do that and can't
pick 0 you got to pick one because this
is about priorities and each one tells
you how much money you're going to save
and at the end of the process about
eight or ten pairs it'll tell you how
much money you saved over one year in
ten years and we're gonna do this and
then I'm gonna give you some interesting
information about what we're finding
because a lot of people have done this
fifty thousand people have visited this
site forty thousand have actually
clicked all the way through and
completed it submitted their email and
hit submit and that's incredible eighty
percent retention rate people care about
this and the results are very
fascinating okay let's go ahead and do
it okay we're getting started and now we
have our first pair do we want to
eliminate the Department of Energy and
transfer the nuclear portion to the
Defense Department or do we want to end
the welfare portion of the child tax
credit program you can see the numbers I
don't know if they're large enough for
you to read two hundred and ten billion
for energy two hundred and sixty five
billion for child credit payments over
ten years okay show of hands who would
rather get rid of the Department of
Energy okay child credit payment energy
losses
okay next Social Security retirement
raise the retirement age to 70 it's
currently on its way to going up to 67
so it would raise it even more for
people born after 1951 that includes me
or should we reduce Social Security
benefits for those with high incomes
means-test
okay retirement age means-test okay I
think retirement age wins so we just
saved 56 billion in the first 10 years
eliminate farm subsidies some farm
subsidies or remove the cap on how much
the government recoups in SSI
overpayments SSA is like a welfare
program run through Social Security farm
subsidies SSI okay what is a hard core
audience farm subsidies are gone no
farmers apparently here okay you can see
by the bar there were about halfway down
flood insurance get rid get rid of
national flood insurance for people who
live you know in areas with repeatedly
flooded homes or Block Grant cash
welfare we reformed welfare in 1996 but
there's plenty more welfare programs
that could be blocked granted
okay flood insurance see hands or cash
welfare that's the big winner there all
right eliminate the ethanol Tax Credit
okay I take it there's a lot of ethanol
fans here eliminate ethanol tax credit
or block-grant food stamps food stamps
show your hands ethanol show your hands
okay whoa ethanol is really unpopular
okay
eliminate the National Endowment for the
Arts which is rather small savings or
eliminate the Legal Services Corporation
also modest legal services National
Endowment for the Arts oh equally
divided I'm going to say NEA goes oh
yeah well we're not writing your names
down and no one goes to jail federal
employee travel cut that or reduce
discretionary spending back to the 2008
level before the current obama surge
there's a I think a big disparity in
savings their discretionary spending to
save a lot more money okay cut employee
federal employee travel discretionary
spending okay almost unanimous eliminate
mass transit grants or eliminate all
earmarks mass transit grants earmarks
whoa earmarks whoops okay so what have
we saved on our first year we've saved
one hundred and ten billion dollars
congratulations you did that without
breaking a sweat
and over ten years we've saved one point
seven trillion dollars half a trillion
more than the supercommittee is being
asked to do and I would ask you if we
did all of those policy changes that we
just agreed to as a game would the world
have ended no so the point is this can
be done that we can get popular support
now let's look at the results from the
public
okay here they are the top ten
budget cuts based on the 40,000 people
who've done this so far
number one repeal Obamacare
ninety-three percent of people when
given this as against some other
possible budget cut choose this 93
percent favorability number to cut out
duplicative purchases of obsolete
Pentagon supplies they waste a lot of
money in the Pentagon on supplies that
wouldn't necessarily eliminate any
weapons programs just waste number three
privatize Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac 81
percent favorability rating number four
eliminate the Department of Education
but that always gets the biggest line in
our town hall applause line number six
Block Grant Medicaid number seven the
your ethanol tax credit makes the top
ten list number eight closed down unused
and underused federal buildings number
nine eliminate HUD and number ten
eliminate earmarks so there you have it
the top ten cuts and guess how much you
would save if we did those ten things
six trillion dollars over ten years as
much as the Paul Ryan budget and five
times as much as the supercommittee is
being asked to do last little point on
this left right and center people agree
on these cuts
sorry oh shoot
there we go these seven items are agreed
by people who describe themselves as
Republicans Democrats independents and
liberals or libertarian excuse me
and there's some of the same ones you
saw in the general top list these seven
cuts would save four point seven
trillion dollars over ten years and this
is left right and center so again there
is popular support for doing this if we
have to do it these are where the
priorities are now I have to finish with
just saying there's not a lot of support
for doing deep cuts in Medicare and
Social Security and there's not a lot of
support for deep cuts in defense at
least among those who took this survey
but I believe there is hope because when
people are forced to choose they will
make serious choices and what needs to
happen
long-term I believe is people need to
understand that these big entitlements
are not legally vested rights they are
not legally enforceable property they
are essentially welfare programs and the
private sector as we've seen in Chile
and other countries can deliver better
benefits with the same or better
security ladies and gentlemen there is
hope and we thank you for supporting the
tea party movement
well we had a very wonderful panel here
and I'm glad that all of you were able
to get up so early and and bright-eyed
and bushy-tailed what we're going to do
now is we're going to have questions and
we have to you lovely young ladies here
that will be walking around with
microphones so if you'll raise your hand
and if you will wait until you get the
microphone and if you will if you're
addressing it to the entire panel let us
know that if you're addressing it to a
particular person on the panel let us
know that thank the panel that was an
outstanding presentation and this is
directed at the whole panel I am very
curious about your opinion on Paul
Ryan's budget I personally thought there
were a lot of excellent items in it but
given the highly-charged sense of
politics around it what do you think can
happen in the short term and the long
term and again this is directed for the
panel thank you can I go ahead and take
that the Paul Ryan budget we at Freedom
Works supported strongly but it
disappointed us in some ways he took
Social Security off the table he took
defense off the table effectively so a
lot of his cuts were focused on Medicare
and interestingly he didn't generate
much savings there in the first 10 years
his reforms didn't even start until
after the tenth year and yet and all he
did was basically give seniors more
choices of privately competing private
insurance plans so basically making
Medicare a better more efficient benefit
and for this there were ads run on TV by
the left saying we were throwing grandma
off the cliff
so the mildest possible thing but there
was one flaw from our perspective in
Paul Ryan's Medicare Plan
he he didn't make it voluntary he just
puts everybody in this new competitive
system Medicare is not voluntary as it
is you don't have a choice you go into
Medicare or you lose your Social
Security benefits a lot of people don't
know that and so for us we would say go
ahead and move let people opt into a
Paul Ryan like system in fact that
system is already set up it's called
Medicare
Vantage but encourage people to go into
it and also give them the freedom to
opt-out of Medicare altogether and have
their own good private health insurance
outside the system how much trouble were
in III - I like Paul Ryan's plan a lot I
think it's actually his first road map
was better than his second road map
which was better than the actual budget
he produced because he had to extort of
compromised politically to get there but
his his plan if his plan had passed our
national debt would have increased by
seven trillion dollars over the next ten
years which shows how much trouble were
actually in I would I basically agree
with everything that Dean and Michael
said the one thing I want to add is that
I would like to see the Department of
Defense become the Department of Defense
and not the Department of offense and I
think we could save hundreds of billions
of dollars a year and I'd like to see
someone go after that seriously we are
subsidizing Korea whose GDP is 40 times
that of North Korea we're subsidizing
Britain Germany Italy and we're in a
bunch of wars without really much reason
anymore for being in those wars and I
think we could cut the Pentagon defense
spending I should say military spending
from about 700 billion a year to about
250 or 300 billion a year
this is not a new idea
back when John Kasich was the chairman
of the House Budget Committee and was
going through negotiations with Clinton
and Clinton shut the government down and
blamed it on the Republicans John Kasich
had a dynamite interview on PBS where he
described those negotiations and it was
quite enlightening but he had a plan to
abolish the Commerce Department he said
this would give the Congress cover if
they just abolished the whole department
and this was his way to end corporate
welfare which was started years before
and it was given to multinational
corporations such as McDonald's an ADM
and everybody else to help them compete
in the global market those payments are
still being made to all of those huge
corporations when I don't think they
need help in the competing in the global
market so I would suggest that you add
to your list of priorities to abolish
the Commerce Department transfer what
needs to be in the State Department to
them and once and for all
get rid of global corporations receiving
taxpayer dollars really it's just a gift
can I take that one and anyone else yeah
corporate welfare is a problem and the
the relationship between government and
corporations naturally tends to become
corrupt crony capitalism is a recurring
problem and a current problem so we had
Freedom Works would totally agree and by
the way folks all over the country in
our our field hearings or town halls on
the budget make the same point that you
just
did I would mention that of all the
budget plans we saw this spring from
Paul Ryan all the way over to Rand Paul
of Kentucky the only one that actually
eliminated any cabinet agencies was Rand
Paul's he eliminated four departments
not only Commerce which you mentioned
but also energy education and HUD his
his father Ron Paul has now outdone him
he would add interior to that list my
corporate finance students this fall
help them understand the time value of
money did a first version of
extrapolating out what our current
entitlement programs look like and so
forth and it's a very simple exercise
and what they've arrived at is if we had
four and a half percent growth in the
economy between 2013 and 2020 they ston
some fiscal conservative getting into
the White House in the next fall and so
forth we would end up with a twenty one
point five trillion dollar GDP in 2020
and at fifteen percent taxes we would
end up with about three point three
trillion dollars of income coming in and
yet they've now extrapolated out all
these entitlement programs and of course
it's just it's it's untenable to keep
going with that and I'm wondering why is
it that the current Republican field
that's in the process of these primaries
don't understand the window of
opportunity they have to be the person
that goes right out to the American
people and lays these numbers out and
and makes it aware to everybody on these
national audiences as opposed to these
smaller conservative get-togethers that
we have and I just wonder why no one has
that kind of fortitude to lay this all
out and make it very clear to the
American people and I wonder what your
thoughts would be on that
could I like first of all I think it's a
great idea but if I've watched almost
all the debates and probably 70 to 80
percent at least of each debate and they
don't get time and they can't use props
I mean look at look at how effectively
Dean used pictures and showing you
numbers and they can't do that and so I
think that's that's the answer to your
question and certainly I think Ron Paul
has enough courage I don't think Romney
does I'm not sure who else does
probably Gary Johnson does but he's not
in those debates but anyway I think that
it takes some doing remember Reagan did
that in 81
when he compared the Democratic the
Democrats tax rate cut with his own tax
rate cut he did went on national TV did
it very effectively so you're right it
can be done but you got to have time let
me give you the one caution christian
area note and that is the problem is
that the benefits are given primarily to
people who vote and the bill is given to
people who don't the the likelihood of a
person's voting is roughly the
equivalent of their age 70 percent of 7
year olds vote and 30 percent of 30 year
olds vote and it's pretty much a line
and as long as that's the case
congressman is all congressman and
presidential candidates are always going
to pander to the seventy-year-old and
they are going to pass that bill on to
the to the 30-year old to show you just
how bad it is one of the debates that it
was to see an N debate they asked about
the Medicare prescription drug benefit
of George Bush which adds 17 trillion
dollars to the unfunded liabilities of
the Medicare program every one of the
candidates that they asked even Ron Paul
who they all said oh no I would not
repeal the Medicare prescription drug
benefit Ron Paul said well if we cut the
cut spending on foreign military
adventures we'd have the money to be
able to pay for for and the others just
said oh no we're in favor of Medicare
prescription drugs for seniors so so I
mean nobody's willing to take on you
know there's an ad running right now if
you all seen on CNN you know we're 50
million AARP members you know that that
terrifies
for office can i riff on that I do think
the one thing that produces real change
is fear in the heart of a politician and
the one thing that produces fear in the
heart of a politician is is the prospect
of unemployment so so we at Freedom
Works focus on that we want to help
align their fears with our hopes and and
and this one shameless plug Freedom
Works is the only group on the right
whose endorsement of a candidate
actually moves numbers to two studies
now have shown this our endorsement adds
two to four percentage points to a
candidates vote total so if you're
thinking of running about for office
next year come come see us I have
another shameless plug
my name is qua I'm from Sterling College
in Kansas and this is the first time
I've been here and I want to express my
appreciation for the glossy
presentations in organization by hue
still my and I hope that you will send
your children to Sterling college so
that we can have a budget surplus my
questions are interrelated number one in
business for example when we talk about
budget the expense part is the part that
we can actually control and I know we
talked a lot about Texas and expenses
what can I emphasis should we put in
expenses control and number two if we
look at our history it is very very
clear the economy is going to go up and
down should we really have a budget and
a budget surplus so that we might
cushion
this kind of event and the third one is
this the Bible says for example in
second Thessalonians chapter 3 verse 10
those who are not work they shall not
eat and and that is that is for those
who are able of course how would that
impact the budget the economy and what
we are talking about
let me address the the expended to the
dis pending portion people talk about we
have a revenue problem in in Washington
and it's true revenues are down at a
very low level primarily because of the
the the economic slowdown a little bit
because of the Bush tax cuts but
primarily because economic slowdown
we're down at the low end of those
charts that David was showing CBO
projects that by 2020 we're going to be
a twenty point eight percent of GDP in
terms of revenue that if we then that
includes by the way if we extend the
Bush tax cuts and we abolish the
alternative minimum tax we will still be
at twenty point eight percent of GDP by
2020 which is about two points higher
than the historic average and we would
still have an enormous deficit because
federal spending will be at twenty-five
percent of GDP in 2020 so you know does
anyone think that the problem is on the
revenue side rather than on the
expenditure side you know when you have
those numbers I mean clearly it's a
question of reducing government spending
not a question of how can we raise more
taxes yeah I think you cannot balance
the budget by raising taxes cannot be
done unless you passive that I'm trying
to draw David Henderson out on his iron
law well okay
wait so let me just respond because Dean
made a bit of made a big point of it in
his talk about my iron law it is always
true that if you look at a historical
period and try to project it forward
you're taking a risk and I think frankly
Dean put his finger correctly and what
on on the risk I'm talking with in the
current way we raise or lower taxes
namely income taxes and corporate taxes
and so on but I do think that a VAT is a
game changer and by the way who's this
guy in the Republican primaries who's
pushing a bat it's Herman Cain and I
think that's very dangerous
yeah I can hear the grumbling out there
already it it's sold as a national sales
sales text but if you actually look at
the way it's assessed its it's
essentially a business profits tax and
it's at each level of production so it's
this functionally the equivalent of a
bath
it really is fair yeah and even if it is
just a national retail sales tax paid at
the cash register Keynes 999 it will
evolve into a VAT I think just as they
did in Europe those European vats I
think all of them or most of them
started out life as cash register sales
taxes they will have one last question a
lot of people being relieved from debt
foreclosure filing bankruptcy and it's
been my impression that amusing mr.
Clancy's words there's not the fear in
the heart of the American people when
they consider a default by the American
government do you agree with that it
doesn't seem like people think that
that's such a bad thing and what can we
do to educate people or to make it
obvious that the debt relief that's been
going on on an individual basis and is
not necessarily going to be the same as
what it would would be for the
government if we did default on
everything okay so I would rather see
the kinds of reforms happen that Dean
Clancy talked about then to see a
default I'm just I tend to be a glass
half-full kind of person so when you
look at an issue of default I start
thinking well are there any good aspects
of that and I think the good one is well
the two good ones the one I talked about
which is you then have essentially a
balanced budget amendment with teeth but
the other one is if they default what
else do they not do think about Mike
Tanner's
three kinds of debt if they default on
the debt that they're legally obligated
to pay
they might also default on some of those
other programs and so it's messy it's
ugly
and it's why I have a very high saving
rate even at age sixty but it's it might
be and again I hope deems method works
and more power to you but if it doesn't
there here's this other thing that could
work so I see it as an extreme not that
I want that extreme I'm just saying it
might actually have some good aspects to
it
pension funds all these that hold
government debt all of which would would
be in trouble to the extent they held
Treasury bills Yeah right right yeah
yeah if I could just add to that I
totally agreed with David's point in his
talk and just now that default is not
the worst possible option in the great
debt ceiling debate of this past summer
I personally do not believe that we
would have defaulted I believe that
August 2nd was a false deadline and
Congress was played for dupes on that
and you know they fell into the the left
trap but default isn't a great thing but
it should never be taken off the table
because if it is you lose all your
leverage and if a government does
default what's the real result people
learn not to trust that government
you